más
y
la única clínica de abordo de misisipí
continúa atendiendo pacientes mientras
el futuro del derecho a la suspensión
voluntaria del embarazo en eeuu está en
juego la corte suprema- examina una ley
de misisipí que prohibiría la mayoría de
los abortos después de 15 semanas de
gestación los funcionarios estatales
están utilizando el caso como un
vehículo para pedir a los jueces que
revoquen lo que ha sido conocido como
roe versus wade la histórica decisión de
1973 que estableció al derecho
constitucional al aborto es muy posible
que estemos al borde de una era en la
que la corte suprema- envía roe versus
wade al montón de cenizas de la historia
a donde pertenece si el tribunal anula
el precedente cualquier estado sería
libre de prohibir lo algo que es
probable que hagan unos 26 estados
marcados en naranja en este mapa con
solo aceptar escuchar el caso los jueces
indican que están preparados para
revisar fallos anteriores el tribunal
supremo fue reformado drásticamente en
los últimos años por donald trump quien
se encargó de reemplazar a los
defensores de los de las mujeres con
jueces más conservadores
el impacto de eso fue evidente a
principios de septiembre cuando el
tribunal rechazó una solicitud para
bloquear una ley de texas que prohíbe el
aborto después de seis semanas de
embarazo cuando la mayoría de mujeres no
se han dado cuenta de su estado la ley
de aborto más restrictiva de eeuu
provocó protestas por los derechos de
las mujeres en todo el país queremos
asegurarnos de que el tribunal supremo
sepa que no puede pisotear los derechos
de la mitad de la población la ley de
texas confía en los ciudadanos comunes
la misión de hacer cumplir la
prohibición del aborto
recompensándolos con al menos 10 mil
dólares si demandar a cualquiera que
haya ayudado a proporcionar un
procedimiento ilegal en otros estados
ahora controlados por los republicanos
como alabama y luisiana cuyas
prohibiciones han sido anuladas
anteriormente por orden judicial ahora
también están pensando en utilizar la
misma estrategia de texas se espera que
la corte suprema tome una decisión final
en junio